we have this story from Forbes Velma is
the third worst rated TV show in IMDb
history yo what were they thinking I was
listening to some reviews and I think
this is what Brett was saying over Pop
Culture crisis that basically the show
is hated by everybody and by Design like
you'd think the Velma show Frozen
familiar it's it's a prequel to
Scooby-Doo which retcons A Pup Named
Scooby-Doo which offended everybody but
digress
you'd think that when they make a show
that's woke it's to piss off the right
to generate virality and then the left
would be like haha but I like it because
the right hates it nah apparently
they've made the show extremely a racist
offensive homophobic and gay at the same
time so everybody hates it I haven't
actually watched it but I want to I want
to explain exactly what I'm very very
mad about right so they they do this
this you know Velma thing where look at
this that's Shaggy okay this is Shaggy
now a lot of people are saying why is
why is Shaggy black and why is Velma a
Indian you know I gotta be honest I
don't really care all that much you know
I understand people get mad about the
race swapping thing and I'm like they're
trying to make the characters diverse my
I guess the problem was they couldn't
make a black stone guy because Shaggy is
a stoner who eats a lot of food and does
drugs and so instead they made him
Norville they made him a beta male I'm
not exaggerating apparently like that's
a character Arc for him where he's a
beta male he likes Velma that Bell's
meet velma's meeting him I'm gonna tell
you why I'm very offended by this
because we just got what's called Ultra
Instinct Shaggy and it was one of the
greatest cartoon developments ever like
Ultra Instinct Shaggy destroys
multiverses so so uh Warner Brothers
puts out this video game called
multiverses
with two hilarious things
Shaggy is trying to eat a sandwich when
Arya Stark slices it in half and so he
basically goes Super Saiyan he's so
angry they didn't get a sandwich that he
becomes Godlike and all-powerful and
that was just one of the funniest things
I've ever seen
they got rid of that with the stupid HBO
show making him weak Velma in
multiversus her super ability was to
call the police on you and she called
the police on LeBron James who gets
arrested and then the cop drives off the
edge of the map and then you know LeBron
dies and uh they got rid of that because
it was offensive and it's like guys
you're hitting gold here these are funny
fun things that make us laugh it's not a
bug it's a feature instead they're
retconning and destroying everything and
making this weird garbage Velma show
that nobody wants to watch
it's supposed to be the history of Velma
like the before whatever the prequel
yeah but they they they made her fat fat
gay and Indian one of the criticisms is
that they they basically Mindy Kaling
who created this and plays the voice of
Velma the girl from the office if you
don't know she's in the office um
basically just inserted herself into the
show so this is like the Mindy Kaling
show in the guise of like Velma but it
has nothing to do with Velma or velma's
personality or velma's character from
what that's one of the criticisms I read
I still haven't seen it Daphne's Asian
and Fred is a a rich white guy with a
small dick yeah I'm not that's
apparently a part of the show I think
that's the only part of the show I think
that's the theme it's like okay yeah now
I just gotta say this is proof that the
global Elites are trying to destroy him
I'm kidding there's no Scooby-Doo either
yeah
what made Scooby-Doo Scooby-Doo was that
a stoned guy was eating dog food with
his dog that was just the funniest thing
you know yeah Shaggy was like oh I'm
gonna eat dog food now and you're like
it was like a little bit for everybody I
think you mentioned the diversity
there's a nerdy girl a hot girl a stoner
dude and like a jock dude everybody
could relate in some way to that you
know for the most part either all white
and then there's the the goofy dog you
know that you could be like okay at
least awesome the dog was the best part
I used to like that series and now to
have someone just try to reinvent the
wheel take it over and make it theirs
and destroy it it's just like okay one I
think of an original idea stop trying to
hijack all the other Classics out there
I'm also hearing that there's a two
minute long scene where allegedly 15
year old girls are butt naked and
fighting each other in suggestive uh
positions uh yeah because they're all
like they're like high schoolers I think
yeah so like lots of inappropriate lots
of crazy stuff here I only played it
just to just to kind of see a little bit
of it and I'm like this is this is
insane I can't believe this was just
this was okayed by people I can't
believe this was like yeah this is the
big news today like we're starting the
show and I'm like look what's the big
news and he's like Velma Velma
apparently everyone is mad everybody's
mad they ruined Scooby-Doo yeah and I'm
you know my thing is outside of the
Velma stuff I think this is the
the the Apex the center of the Maelstrom
that is the collapse of
our culture we've we've we've
regurgitated and beaten subject matter
and and themes to a point where we've
made this like we keep rebooting
Spider-Man every couple years we keep
rebooting Batman
Transformers there's nothing original
left there's no new music I mean look
look I bring this one up Christmas time
comes around we listen to the exact same
songs from the 40s and 50s right it's
like yo there was a period where those
songs were new and granted we got like
that Mariah Carey one all I want is
Christmas for All I want for Christmas
is you but for the most part very little
new things are being developed we are
stagnant and this is like okay now it's
crumbled to Ash they keep remaking
Scooby-Doo they make new Scooby-Doo
movies they make you know Scooby-Doo in
the video game and we're like we get it
man these characters are all you have
now
you know you make a copy of a copy of a
copy just gets worse every time we're at
the point where you can't even decide
you're just like what is this it's like
you take a menu from a restaurant you
copy it then you copy the copy and it's
kind of grainy then you copy the copy
and you're like it looks like gibberish
then you copy the copy and it's smudge
that's what this is It's just done it's
done I don't know where we go from here
without Scooby-Doo well you cut opiates
out of your diet if you're taking them
that's one way to get your creativity
back
but but they destroyed the the core
element of the show which was the kind
of sense of of a friendship this friend
this like this sense of like Hey we're
gonna figure out this problem together
we're gonna work together and that was
that was you know it was cool to see all
the teamwork but now this show from what
I've seen from the first episode is I'm
a strong independent woman I'm gonna
solve everything and I'm the best
doesn't she like murder some dude or
something in the trailer she like
murders a guy that was another big
criticism is that they don't even like
each other yeah they hate each other and
they keep like fighting and ridiculing
each other and making fun I like each
other's private parts even though
they're like supposed to be 15 years old
I like that Family Guy joke where Peter
says something like it's almost as as
scary as the Scooby-Doo Murder Mysteries
and the murder files or whatever and
then it shows like no back to Scooby-Doo
Murder Mysteries and then Fred is like
he gutted the victim removed his
intestines and then strangled him with
it we're dealing with one sick son of a
just the idea of like the actual
mystery involving murder for Scooby-Doo
would just be hilarious yeah because
like you know what's funny about
Scooby-Doo is the mystery was always
that like some real estate developer was
trying to drop property value to like
yeah every time and so he dressed up
like a ghost to scare people so they
wouldn't buy the property you know
people do they just shoot guns in their
backyard property value drops I wouldn't
be surprised if they're trying to save
Scooby for uh
um season two and uh they're probably
gonna make him a pit bull and they're
probably gonna make the Pitbull attack a
bunch of babies yeah I guess but with
the way the show's going I see that as
an actual plot
they're gonna uh oh baby exist Scooby's
first appearance would be the last
episode of the first season it's just so
so obvious and predictable would have
been at the end of the first season they
probably already have it planned out
they're like I'm so excited dude if
you're if your is crap it doesn't
matter what your plans are because it
ain't gonna work this Show's not gonna
last more than six episodes I mean maybe
they're already made don't don't mark my
words on that but it's the third lowest
rated television show in history on IMDb
at the moment I don't know how many
votes are in on it 1.3 out of 10. look
at these good luck it's a I think it's
worse than Santa Inc which is whoa Santa
remember that yeah that is impressive
the Seth Rogen Sarah Silverman it's the
fifth worst rated thing on IMDb
they seem to have badly scraped the idea
of an elf wanting to become Santa Claus
or Scooby could be a furry right
a part of the the acceptance movement
and then and then they could be Velma
and Scooby could be getting it on dude
if it was a guy that got imprisoned and
genetically experimented on and turned
into a dog but you gotta do that in
episode one because that would be cool
maybe that's what they're doing like
Norville is actually gets turned into
Scooby and that you know and that that's
why he's not Shaggy oh and I think the
real shaggy is but he's like I can't
tell him the truth it's part of this
experiment I turn a dog into a guy and a
guy into a dog and that's the origin of
Scooby-Doo and that's why he can talk
because hey why can Scooby talk it makes
sense he's a chimera he's a kid I have
no other explanation like why can't we
get just something original I guess you
got to make it well Eric July made that
made the rep reverse stuff so you know
there's people trying you can try yeah I
still think a psychic gorilla is going
to be the next big superhero what do you
mean segarat's Grodd grad is a villain
but is he a space gorilla Gorilla Grodd
is from gorilla City and he's he can
control people's brains and he's a bad
guy and he's psychic we need a cosmic
gorilla good guy that's a psychic you
know it's kind of funny in Marvel they
have wakanda which is like you guys know
what Condes will conda wakanda yeah like
in in the the country of wakanda in
Africa they have a force field they hide
in DC they have Gorilla city which is
like basically the same thing but
everybody's a gorilla
I'm like I wonder why they did that you
know I mean that's that seems kind of
weird oh my gosh yeah it's like wait a
minute hold on a second yeah that's what
DC made I wonder like who made it first
because they would do this thing where
like Marvel has a DC I think I can't
remember who did it first I think maybe
Slade
so there's two characters there's
Deathstroke and Deadpool and they're
very similar characters although
Deadpool eventually became comedic and
Deathstroke is a very serious character
Deathstroke is DC Deadpool is Marvel
and so they talk about how there's like
always this back and forth I I always
wondered about that like the analog for
wakanda is a gorilla City like was that
racist
yes it sounds like it but I don't know
which came first gorilla City or wakanda
I don't know I don't know but gorilla
garad it was a bad guy he wanted to take
over the world because he he was
basically killmonger but a gorilla
that's kind of weird to me Jay what
would a philosopher say about this uh
incredible content and entertainment
that is fed to the American public
my thought was this is it's maoist like
the way that this has to be pushed and
it's always like going a little further
like the dogma of this right and you
know maoism is a cultural revolution to
change everything that came before so I
just see it as kind of like a rewriting
of everything even down to the point of
like the most mundane pop culture stuff
has to be Rewritten has to be
revolutionized in that way right like
getting rid of all the four olds like
all the old culture old religion I don't
think it's kind of like it's happening
now all the old things are like you are
unacceptable you can't have them and if
you redone remade we've been watching my
wife and I've been watching old like 40s
movies which it's amazing the degree
even in those the propaganda that
existed like particularly warprop again
the americanist propaganda but in terms
of like ethics is they're all pretty
wholesome you know 40s era stuff is I
mean compared to like what's now but
it's just bizarre to see how far it's
gone from like 40s era to now like the
the revolution is complete and they're
actually gonna I think they're gonna
start like Banning
movies that are before a certain date
like you won't they're gonna say you
can't I mean Bruce Russell talks about
that he's like you're not going to be
reading Shakespeare in the future you're
not going to read Mark Twain You're
going to read Flannery O'Connor you're
not going to watch you know movies
before a certain date or they'll be
purged in some way or edited in some way
so that's right Disney already has
warnings saying hey this this movie is
racist like Snow White exactly which is
absolutely crazy preservation of data
we'll have to hide our data it's
literally we'll have to store our data
in Hidden like glass cubes in orbit
things where you can if you get the
coordinates hit it with a laser and read
the data or something like that we're
really gonna have to protect our data I
didn't think it was going to come to
that but we do not only from asteroids
no wait there apparently Scoobies in the
show but it's
s-c-o-o-b-i and it's some black chick
what really oh that's what people are
saying it's not even sure a dog no it's
sort of insinuating yeah exactly oh
right is that for real
I I think it automatically changed
Scooby back to we were talking about
Scooby-Doo last year I forgot oh it was
the LeBron James oh yeah pop culture
crisis covered it Scooby Scooby Velma
turned Scooby-Doo into a black woman
yeah what that's kind of weird why would
they that's racist it kind of is Scooby
that's her name her name is Scooby and
and Norville dates her oh man pop
culture crisis covered it look at that
what Scooby's like doobie right Scooby
Dooby you know smoking that oh yeah
what's Scooby Dooby Doo that dog was on
drugs
but they're like figuring out right
so they're like they're real they're
like you know the guy in the uh Cabin in
the Woods like the the guy that's the
stoner guy but he actually figures
everything out yeah that character oh
wasn't it like the weed was a lot of the
Breakthrough and see what was going on
but like no they're really controlling
us the puppet Master's right and there
really were Republicans yeah that movie
was awesome I remember when people
someone I remember was like Hey when the
movie came out people were asking me
have you seen Cabin in the Woods I'm
like I'm not gonna go see that movie
like a movie dumb teenagers go to the
cabin in the woods and get murdered and
they're like that's not what it's about
you know I've noticed about smoking I
went to go see it for those that aren't
familiar it's about a Trope of people
that the the Scooby-Doo gang the nerdy
girl the hot girl the Jack and the
stoner going to a cabin and then there's
a gigantic underground complex of people
trying to sacrifice them to moloch or
whatever yeah that's correct that's the
old ones yeah the old ones that was
funny what I found was fun with weed and
the value of it in like perception
because you know it does change your
perception is that it's kind of like
holding a magnifying glass and and the
more you smoke the further away the
glass gets so you want to get it to
right the right position so that you can
see the thing but if you do too much it
becomes blurry if you don't do enough
it's still blurry kind of things you
want a Scooby Snack dosing every day dog
I think dosage the key in the whole drug
war it's not about the drug it's about
the dosage of the content like what is
the chemical what is the dosage fentanyl
is not going to kill you in the right
dosage
but the unfortunate thing is that
conversation probably hasn't been
highlighted enough yet and the dosage is
like overlooked in some situations I
don't want to manifest that because we
can focus on dosage yeah but I think
there there's so many psychedelics are
are going to be a key component in the
preservation of our species moving
forward Against the Machine feels like
it anyway
that is hijacked the conversation
we're talking about Scooby Snacks I
think and then we're talking oh yeah
yeah you get me on Shaggy I'm gonna go
nuts yeah I mean there's like the whole
of the whole theory about like help yeah
I think it's Paul stamets said that we
ate we ate um psilocybin mushrooms and
that like made us then you know see
things then think more and it allowed
our brain to develop because it
increased like the connection between
neurons etc etc that's what Jay was
saying with uh Terence McKenna and it's
called The Stone date is that what that
is I think it originates with Terence
McKenna yeah
okay and then stametsu is a fungologist
or whatever you call the greatest
Mycologist Mycologist on Earth Paul
stamets thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time